hello everyone on the youtubes and the
mug clubs listen this is actually coming
to you sounds probably not very good I'm
not my wife this evening this that top
of the hill somewhere in Big Bear Lake
well you guys know that we have someone
a special coming for you Monday on this
channel beyond Tuesday both me and not
gage eared are going to be on the Joe
Rogan experience to call that from Joe's
show we're actually talking with Joe let
some of our undercover stuff and what
we're doing with the new show here the
new year and Thursday is big Thursday is
February 1st February 1st yeah and it's
the biggest show we ever done I don't do
a lot of these updates could I hate the
vlog Channel look look at my Kmart halt
by the way in Big Bear I found the Kmart
I found the Kmart left in the United
States and they didn't they didn't have
snow pants which surprised me I had to
go to uh I think I think a big 5
sporting goods store to get snow pants
and it was a whole Trek just get some
snow pants something else I've also
learned walking stick is of actual use I
don't know if you know this when I was a
kid I used to take walking sticks with
me when I would go hiking just because I
suffer at penner do it but you'd be
walking with a stick like this it was a
detriment you got to use it properly and
my what a useful tool the walking stick
I think I'll take up whittling so listen
I know this is a long weekend for me the
team had some time off Christmas New
Year's I'll tell you this since really I
would say probably June 2016 and I
haven't had a good amount of time off I
come up for air with was Christmas New
Year's and we have a lot of new
sponsorships new agreements and move
into a new studio who just hired three
new people with with the potential of a
fourth in spending some time out here
not only felt good I you know I had to
go to LA to do Joe Rogan my wife and I
said let's just take a long weekend and
go to Big Bear where we can do nothing
and walk around it's it's it's odd I
don't sound silly because this is
usually I hate vlogs but it's made me
realize it for about a year and a half
I I don't know myself outside of the
pressure cooker of the daily show and
constantly going and constantly working
and not like I've lost myself not that
I'm a different person but as far as how
my brain works and how I'm able to react
in the amount of time I'm able to have
this is the first time in a long time
where I just shut off my phone and went
for a few hours with the thermos and my
wife right by the way this is no I don't
know if I can use their their name and
appreciating guess which thermos this is
all those hipsters with the hydro flasks
and the clean canteens and the yetis
it's not even close to just the seems
like an old-school thermos they've been
around for years it's been good and it's
also made me realize how much I
appreciate what it is that we do in and
support you guys have given us and the
ability to be a blessing to other people
who we hire I mean there are a couple
stores I can't I can't necessarily tell
you but there's someone who we don't
have a space to hire yet because we are
moving into a new space and you know
contracts and leases but this person was
was so grateful for the opportunity when
we all just felt grateful to to even
know this person with this kind of
talent to come on to produce this show
and it's it's really an incredible time
so it's been good for me to just take a
long weekend spend time with my wife
finally and I'm looking forward to doing
Joe Rogan's show on Tuesday looking
forward to getting back into the swing
of things huge show and of course by the
way
Virginia Tech February 6th we are going
to be broadcasting for the first time
live no not live on YouTube but we had
some we've had some hard strike so he
can't stream live right now because mr.
Rogers claimed copyright with direct we
did those songs with our own keyboard as
far as parody anyway I'm rambling I
guess nature does this to you but
February 6 will be at Virginia Tech we
will be streaming live on CR TV for the
first time that's gonna be the full lot
or throughout our live show and some
interactive sketches as well as QA so
Monday something special come on in
Tuesday Joe Rogan experience February
first Thursday shows back in full swing
and then February 6 Virginia Tech the
first time we take the live show on the
road a lot more to come looking forward
to seeing you guys and I cannot tell you
I
it sound like one of those guys like I
mean I hate the people on YouTube or
just oh man I love the supporters admit
the haters and that's not what my life
is about but genuinely we have encounter
just here in Big Bear just so many
people who who the show is impacted and
I haven't had time to sit back and look
at it so even just four days three days
this weekend just being able to sit back
and go wow this is this is kind of what
we're doing where we're headed look at
the people who it's it's a it's it's
it's a great time on a selfish level it
feels really good but I hope it feels
good for you guys to look for to save
you Monday Tuesday and then Thursday
bike